Okay, so let's continue our discussion
on using transformers
in large data sets to obtain pre-trained
models. And here we want to switch from
the vision transformers to language
models. So the vision transformer idea
actually came after what we are going to
talk about today. Transformers were
initially developed to handle text data
initially in machine translation which
had an encoder and a decoder part to
take in a sequence and output
another sequence. But then later
different parts of the transformer prove
to be useful. And uh Bert here is a way
of encoding text just what just like
what we did for vision transformers
to classify that text. But we first saw
that idea in image classification and
the main reason was we are very familiar
with that since we developed the CNN's
there and we already saw this potential
for learning representations across
images and text. So that basically help
us to double down on this idea of
transfer learning learning a pre-trained
model and then use it for specific
tasks. We want to try that idea in text
and we look at three different
architectures
all transformerbased.
BERT which is the encoder part of the
trans transformer. GPT is only the
decoder part and T5 is the entire
architecture.
So these names Bert, GPG and T5 are like
the most famous person in this family
basically that becomes like a last name
really. But for example in the decoder
part we have llama models that is still
an auto reggressive type of model. Okay.
So we discuss how to train these models
and later we want to fine-tune them
right and we discuss the the way that we
are training them that we call self-s
supervision that is somehow different
than what we did for vision. So, back to
computer vision. Let's say we want to
classify flower types and we have let's
say 5,000 label flower images and we
want to train a CNN with 50 million par
with 50 million parameters and we need a
GPU and maybe a few days of compute or
less depending on the resources that we
have. The question is should we train
from scratch? The answer
back in 2012
was no because we were going to be
overfeit badly with this number of
parameters with and this number of
images we cannot get a good model. But
now that we have a trained CNN possibly
on a very large data set for example
imageet we can use it and fine-tune for
our specific problem. We have done this
before and the idea is there are some
universal features that the pre-trained
model and the large data set learn and
we don't need to learn that anymore and
we can transfer them to the new task.
Hence we can copy the pre-train CNN and
freeze most of the layers and only train
a few layers that corresponds mostly
with the new head that is using the same
features and predict uh different
classes. So after 2012 once we had these
pre-trained models we can fine-tune them
on smaller task specific data sets data
sets that sometimes is very difficult to
collect for example medical imaging due
to many reasons for example privacy
related standards and compliances or
getting good label data. But now that we
have this set up, we can fine-tune our
neural network for this finite data
sets. Hence, this allows us to have
specialized networks on different
specialized domains. So by 2015,
basically this idea was a standard
practice in computer vision. Now the
question is can we do the same for text?
If images have edges, textures and
shapes, well, text has grammar, syntax,
and semantics too that are general
features and we can learn. Well, to
answer that, first we have to say, well,
for the computer vision, we had this
very nice data sets that are labeled and
have this clear task for classification.
Do we have the same for text?
Well, not really because u comparable
label data set for text is either
non-existing
due to the humongous effort that is
required for labeling them or sometimes
really the task is not set in stone and
the task is often time fluid in text. So
that's a problem and how can we solve
that? Well, the answer is maybe we don't
need that and that's how we get to
self-supervised learning. So the idea is
well text contains its own supervision.
Yes, we may not have like cleanly
labeled sentences but we have unlimited
unlabeled text. For example, we have
Wikipedia data set with billions of
tokens, different book data sets again
with billions of tokens. We have web
pages that we can design crawlers and
scrapers to collect data from. And
within text, we have an inherent
structure. For example, we can hide a
word and the model can predict that. We
can basically hide half of the sentence
and the model can generate the other
half. Basically, what I'm trying to say
is text itself provides labels
if we look differently. This is known as
self-supervised learning which the model
creates supervised task for itself from
this unlabeled data. So some other
question for example let's say we have a
sentence like I love this red car and
then we can mask a word here red for
example and make up a task to predict
that token so the model can do the
entire steps no human label is needed.
Another way of making up labels is to do
next token prediction. So we have this
sentence and then we hide the last word
or last token and we ask to predict that
this is known an auto reggressive task.
You can think of other madeup super
signal for shuffling sentences and uh
asking to restore them where again we
have the original document that tells us
the the order. So great can do this for
text but why we didn't do it for images
at the first place. Well, the main
reason was um for text we have a finite
vocabulary and it's easy to design this
self-supervised tasks and often it even
seems natural to do it. For example,
predict this war. I mean we do games
like that given some context or answers
for some question we ask the other
player to predict the war and then we
can use this very efficient crescent for
example here.
That's not the case for images and the
main reason is there we're dealing with
continuous data and there's not really a
finite vocabulary. We're talking about
pixel values and it's very hard because
of that much larger degree of freedom to
do the training. There are some modern
way of uh doing self-supervised learning
for vision now that I'm going to skip
but back then that was not uh the main
way of training computer vision models.
Again, this new updates are available
now because of the advances in the NLP
field that trickled down to computer
vision. Okay, so the transfer learning
will look different now. And here we
have this pre-training stage for text
that is trained on this massive
unlabeled corpus of text. We're talking
about billions of tokens. And this is
done in [snorts] a self-supervised
manner. And this way the model learns
the general features of the language.
And then we can transfer that to more
specialized tasks. For example,
um with top with thousands of examples
that has a specific task that we care
about. Later we will see that even given
if we have a bridge pre-training without
any further training and just by giving
some context within a prompt we get we
can get the answers for our question and
that's where things become very
interesting. Okay. So let's not jump
ahead and continue from the bird family
that started this paradigm of
self-supervised learning. So here we
focus on bird which is the
transformerbased version of them which
is basically an encoder transformer
trained in a self-supervised manner and
language models and then fine-tune
on different tasks. The original paper
for bird showed that for all of these
different NLP tasks achieved
state-of-the-art performance. This
fine-tuning on these tasks often needed
only a few thousands of example. So this
really changed the landscape of NLP
because before bird if we wanted to
train a model for a specific task we
needed to design its own architecture
and its own large label data set and
eventually achieve a model that only
does a specific task. But after this
paradigm shift, one pre-trained model
can be fine-tuned for different tasks
often with small data sets and achieve
strong performance. And that's how
transfer learning became default in NLP.
So we discussed transform transformer
architecture and we said it's modular.
It has this encoder decoder modules and
for these three different families for
example B only uses the encoder GPT only
uses the decoder and this
sequencetosequence models uh with this
flagship T5
model uses both. So if we want to use
both we need a cross attention right
otherwise self attention within the
encoder or decoder is enough. So
whenever we have only the encoder, we
don't really need the causal masking. So
we can look both ways and that's how the
birectional way of training can be
included in bird for example. And for
some T5 or sequence to sequence models
also as long as we're not decoding one
token at a time, we can also train them
in a birectional ways. Okay, so let's
zoom in into Bert, which only uses the
encoder transformer. Like I said, it's a
birectional self attention, meaning that
every token can attend to all other
tokens, and there's no causal mask. We
really don't need that. And the output
can be a contextual representation,
something like the CLS token that we
discuss in vision transformer. Just like
vision transformer, they can be great
for classification, for example,
sentiment analysis. They can feel or
replace tokens and they can also
understand tasks in case we want to use
that for another reason than
classification.
Okay. So let's look at how we are doing
this uh self-supervised learning in
bird. So the procedure for that was to
select 15% of token randomly
and replace 80% of that 50 15% with mask
tokens. 10% of that 15% with random
token. Basically, we replace them with
randomly chosen token from the
vocabulary and then choose another 10%
and keep it on change. So, let's zoom
into uh why this uh 15% is spent like
this. Note that we choose this tokens
and we ask the model to predict them.
When we replace the token with mask
token, basically the mask token is not
providing any information about the
original token. So the model has to look
around and seek context for that. The
10% uh of tokens that are replaced with
a random token is a way to reduce a
train test mismatch. What I mean is
basically during the pre-training if the
model only sees the mask token, it may
only worry about the tokens
representation
uh when it's a mask. So it gets lazy
with the representation of the non-mask
tokens. But by swapping in a random word
chosen from the vocabulary, we force the
model to learn that any word can be
potentially wrong. So it has to rely on
the rely on the context to verify or
correct the token that he's looking at.
So now the question is why we keep 10%
unchange. The reason is this is a way of
balancing out this 10% wrong tokens
because otherwise if we don't have this
and we have only this basically the
model learns this bias that any non-mask
token that I'm asked to predict is
probably wrong but with keeping this
unchanged tokens we force the model to
use the context to confirm if the word
is correct.
So in summary, the mask tokens forces
the model to use the context. The random
tokens reduces this train test mismatch.
And in conjunction with this unchanged
tokens, the model is not sure if a token
is correct or random. So it must always
be cross-checking
uh it against the context. So that's how
we train the birth model. Note that this
is an encoder model which means that we
don't need to have a causal mask. So we
can look from both direction
which makes the the model uh more sample
efficient compared to those that
enforces the the causal masking like the
auto reggressive models like GPT. Okay.
So how to do fine-tuning? Well, if we
have a classification task just like
what we did for vision transformer, we
use the CLS token um and send it to a
softmax to get the logits and send it to
a softmax to get the probabilities.
So the token classification task is also
called named entity recognition or ne.
So the next uh task is really sentence
pairing. So note uh there is a
additional token here that basically
separate the sentences and it's like a
boundary for each sentence and you
already know cls token. So this help us
to now define uh tasks on the sentences
and somehow do natural language
inference which is basically a way of
recognizing this textual entailment that
involves logical relationship between uh
pairs of sentences for example
contradiction
u and entailment. So the other family is
T5. So T5 architectures are using both
encoder and decoder very similar to
sequence tosequence models. But here T5
frames every NLP task as a texttoext
problem. So the original um transformer
uh from the paper attention is all you
need. It introduced an architecture. It
didn't really specify any pre-training
task just like bird for example and it
was designed for a single purpose a
sequencetose sequence task and primarily
for machine translation.
T5 uses the same encoder decoder
architecture
so no modification in the architecture
but reframes the input and output and
it's trained differently from the
transformer. So for example transformer
really they didn't have a pre-training
objective they were trained in a
supervised manner for example
the machine translation where we had
pairs of uh sentences uh for example
from English to German here in T5 we act
we we have pre-training and the
different here with uh for example bird
is here we are not masking tokens we
mask spans of tokens which makes a more
difficult problem. So a span is a
subsequence of tokens and here instead
of the mask token we are using the
sentinel tokens which can be a
subsequence each one of them and the T5
model is learned to generate them. For
example, look at this. Uh we have this
sentence that can have different way of
u span corruption during the
self-supervised stage. So the idea here
is basically encoder learns to compress
and decoder learns to generate. Now
let's look at uh the decoder only
architectures like GPT where they only
use the decoder part or the decoder
module and they use this causal self
attention mask. There's a token at T
only sees the previous tokens. Like I
said they are designed for this auto
reggressive generation tasks. The
training is kind of simple because we
only predict the next token given all
the previous history. And this training
is basically exactly the same as the
inference. So there's not really a
mismatch. And the nice thing about this
type of training is we use everything.
We are not masking or corrupting a span
and then ask the model to predict them.
Instead we ask the model to predict
every token. So every token was a
labeled question at some point in their
life. This makes this uh decoder only
families very scalable in terms of data
efficiency and learning. For example, we
have different GPD models from 2018 to
2020. And in particular, the GPT3 model
came up with this idea of in context
learning. So you don't really need to do
any fine-tuning. As long as you have a
good prompt, the model can fill the
answer for you. So this is by itself
extremely interesting meaning that we
really don't need to do any finetuning.
We just train the model once and then
use it. In other word no parameter
updates is necessary. Instead we give a
prompt for example a prompt like this
that basically gives a few examples of
what I want to do which here is
translation from English to French and
then ask the model to continue. So given
this context, the model basically learns
a new task without changing any
parameters and that's where everything
is basically can be squeezed into the
prompt and the model already knows to
extract the patterns within that context
and match those patterns and continue
like that. So now really the if you
provide examples in the prompt each
example is like a a shot of learning
like one shot is one example for example
here in this case we give two shots and
then ask for our question so this really
gives us a very efficient training for
auto reggressive models or GPG models
because it uses the entire data and it's
great for generation. We discussed this
masking way of super self-supervised
learning. Uh in in bird for example we
only use 15% of the data as supervision
signal of course in a birectional way
and this is great for understanding not
really generating and then we discuss T5
which is using both encoder and decoder
very efficiently and gets benefit from
the both work. Now there are ways to
improve really the birth models. Uh for
example there is this uh um electra
solution that instead of uh doing this
mask language modeling it does replacing
this 15% of token with plausible
alternatives and then discriminate if
they are real or fake. So this way we
basically provide more supervision
signal from the same data. But
eventually the decoder only models or at
least for now they are winning and
mainly because of their simple
architecture they are scaling extremely
well and the in context learning that
emerges out of it gave rise to this chat
application like chat GPT and they can
do basically everything they can
understand tasks they can generate tasks
and they can also uh leave without
fine-tuning and that's why all of this
leading models GPT3, GPT4, llama, etc.